Wednesday I didn't realize this is Back
to the Future day yes from Back to the
Future to that that traveled to in the
future yes it's the day that the movie
came out how many years has been
suspected was 1989 yes yeah and and and
it's the day that's gonna be on
Wednesday 2015 yes and they make all
these predictions in the movie and
people are noticing it's strange a lot
of these predictions have come true have
come true that's right a lot of them
they have what rents to like an Apple
watch yeah they've got flat screens
they've got videoconferencing we don't
have flying cars right but many of these
things have come true
they also predict in Back to the Future
2 that the Cubs will be in the Worlds
here and apparently they're very close
yeah are they actually in the World
Series well there's they're there there
it is reveal the truth about myself baby
bears play baseball yeah they are well
they're not you know in the World Series
they're they're down two games but they
they could make it and it's very
exciting they've gotten closer than they
ever have so people were excited that
these things that the prophecies of the
film are coming true right and I bring
it this up because this was your first
that movie was your first seen in a film
that's right yeah that's pretty crazy
how old were you at the time I was eight
years old you were eight eight and you
had a very small part in back to the
future to high knee in the back of the
cafe 80s trying to work a video game
that Michael J Fox has character but
Marty McFly comes over and works for us
and we declared it's like a baby's toy
because yes to use his hands right which
is you know that in the future which is
so uncool but Elsa was fascinated that
you and your friend in the movie that
your characters are wearing what looks
to be green colander Hollanders on your
heads right so thankfully which was one
that's one thing that's one prediction
I'm really glad didn't turn out to be
true same very hot what a relief but
when anyway we have the clip this is
your first appearance ever an emotion in
a film yeah and Wow hell of a thing to
appear in the back yeah you you hit the
jackpot let's take a look all right
I'll show you kid crack-shot at this
[Music]
your hands that's like a baby's toy
[Applause]
just it I have no idea why this didn't
catch on I know in class aren't they
great really oh yeah there's the wise
guy hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please